today's question comes from tara in
louisiana she says my father recently
passed away and my mother
received 320 000 in life insurance
she is debt free and says she doesn't
need the money since she has enough
assets to live
a comfortable life i have a hundred and
twenty thousand dollars in student loans
that
that she wants to pay off for me because
she feels like this is what my dad would
want
i want i have started following your
baby steps
and have been gazelle intense for the
last six months attacking my debt
this would get me very close to being
debt-free i want to honor my father
and never be in debt i am feeling torn
about this
do i accept the gift yes
i really do i mean i i would definitely
have a conversation with my mom and make
sure
she doesn't feel that you're trying to
force her into it
uh but i agree if it was my daughter um
and i passed away and left this
i would definitely want the money to
help
my family proceed forward in life and
paying off the debt will be a good
steward in my opinion of that
as long as your mom is taken care of
yeah that's what i'm concerned about the
reason i'm concerned about it is you
didn't tell us
that she had how much money she's got
you just said she doesn't have to live a
comfortable life
right and um some moms a comfortable
life is a can of soup a day
that's good if her daughter gets all the
money and she barely makes it by because
she's
broke yeah good point and she calls that
a comfortable life but she took care of
her daughter
yeah uh so i don't know what a
comfortable life
in air quotes means if it means she's
got a million dollars
in a 401k and this is an extra 320 on
top of that
i'll go with that yeah if it means she
can live off of her social security
and be struggling no at 1200 bucks a
month right
and calls that comfortable so you can
have this money
yeah and wrong answer right no
so i i need a better definition of
comfortable life
but uh if she if she you know
has enough assets to live account so she
has some assets so it's not social
security
but you know what is a what's really
there that's what i want to know
yeah i agree and uh but you know the
more money mom has the more i go with
your answer
yes yeah i would definitely accept it
now the other piece of this
is you cannot give someone
that much money without a gift tax being
imposed
unless you do it properly
and so you need to see your mom needs to
see a tax
attorney or a tax professional to help
her file
what's called the unified estate tax
credit exemption and she needs to use up
some
of her estate to avoid paying taxes on
this because if she gives you
more than fifteen thousand dollars she's
going to be taxed at
55 percent and so
do not just write somebody a check in
your family for 120 000
the irs comes in and audits you you're
going to get hammered
and so you need to have some
professional tax guidance
and it's a very simple form and it's
called the unified
estate tax credit and you need to do
that to avoid the gift tax if you guys
go forward with this
and we only go forward with this if
mom's definition of
comfortable is really comfortable
really really really comfortable